you mentioned planaria being in some
sense Immortal uh what's the role of
death in life
what's the role of death in this whole
process we have is is it uh when you
look at biological systems
is death an important feature
especially as you climb up the hierarchy
of uh competency oh yeah that's an
interesting question
um I think that uh it's certainly a
factor that promotes change and turnover
and uh an opportunity to do something
different the next time
um for a larger scale system so
apoptosis you know it's it's really
interesting I mean death is really
interesting in a number of ways one is
like you could think about like what was
the first thing to die you know that's
that's an interesting question what was
the first creature that you could say
actually die it's a tough it's a tough
thing because we don't have a great
definition for it so if you bring a a
cabbage home and you put it in your
fridge
at what point are you going to say it's
died right then so so that's it's kind
of hard
um to know there's also there's also uh
the the there's there's one paper in
which I talk about this idea that I mean
think about think about this and and
imagine that uh you have you have a
creature uh that's aquatic let's say
let's say it's a it's a frog or
something or a tadpole and the animal
dies in the in the pond it dies for
whatever reason
most of the cells are still alive so you
could imagine that if when it died there
was some sort of um breakdown of of of
of the of the connectivity between the
cells a bunch of cells crawled off they
could have a life as amoebas they some
of them could join together and become a
zenabot and toodle around right so we
know from planaria that there are cells
that don't obey the hayflick limit and
just sort of live live forever so you
could imagine an organism that when the
organism dies it doesn't disappear
rather the individual cells that are
still alive crawl off and have a
completely different kind of lifestyle
and maybe come back together as
something else or maybe they don't so so
all of this I'm sure is happening
somewhere on some on some on some Planet
so so
um death in any case I mean we already
kind of knew this because the molecules
we you know we know with something nice
the molecules go through the ecosystem
but even the cells don't necessarily die
at that point they might have another
life in a different uh in a different
way you can think about something like
Gila right The Gila cell line you know
that has this that's had this incredible
life uh there are way more Hela cells
now than there ever been than there than
there were when when she was alive it
seems like as the organisms become more
and more complex like if you look at the
mammals their relationship with death
becomes more and more complex
so the survival imperative starts
becoming interesting and humans
are arguably the first species
that have invented the fear of death
the understanding that you're going to
die let's put it this way like a
long-term so not like in
instinctual like I need to run away from
the thing that's going to eat me but
starting to contemplate the finiteness
of Life yeah I mean one thing so one
thing about the human light cognitive
light cone is that for the first as far
as we know for the first time you might
have goals that are longer than your
life that are not achievable right so if
you're if you're let's say and I I don't
know if this is true but if if you're of
goldfish and you have a 10 minute
attention span I'm not sure if that's
true but let's say let's say there's
some organism with a with a short um you
know kind of cognitive light cone that
way
all of your goals are potentially
achievable because you're probably going
to live the next 10 minutes so whatever
goals you have they are totally
achievable if you're a human you could
have all kinds of goals that are
guaranteed not achievable because they
just take too long like guaranteed
you're not going to achieve them so I
wonder if you know is that is that a per
you know like a perennial um you know
sort of thorn in our in our psychology
that drives some some psychosis or
whatever I have no idea another
interesting thing about that actually
I've been thinking about this a lot in
the last couple of weeks this notion of
giving up so you would think that
evolutionarily the most um adaptive way
of being is that you go you you you
fight as long as you physically can and
then when you can't you can't and
there's in there's this Photograph
there's some videos you can find of
insects crawling around where like you
know this like like most of it is
already gone and it's still sort of
crawling you know like
um um a Terminator style right like as
far as as long as you physically can you
keep going
mammals don't do that so so a lot of
mammals including rats have this thing
where when when they think it's it's a
hopeless situation they literally give
up and die when physically they could
have kept going I mean humans certainly
do this and there's there's some like
really unpleasant experiments that the
the this guy forget his name did with
them drowning rats where if he where
where rats normally drown after a couple
of minutes but if you teach them that if
you just tread water for a couple of
minutes you'll get rescued they can
tread water for like an hour and so
right and so they literally just give up
and die and so evolutionarily that
doesn't seem like a good strategy at all
evolutionarily since why would you like
what's the benefit ever of giving up you
just do what you can and you know one
time out of a thousand you'll actually
get rescued right but this issue of of
of actually giving up suggests some very
interesting metacognitive controls where
you've now gotten to the point where
survival actually isn't the top drive
and that for whatever you know there are
other considerations that have like
taken over and I I think that's uniquely
a mammalian thing but um I don't know
yeah the Camus
the existentialist and question of Why
Live just the fact that humans commit
suicide is a really fascinating question
from an evolutionary perspective and
what was the first and that's the other
thing like what is the simplest uh
system whether whether evolved or you
know natural or whatever that is able to
do that right like you can think you
know what other animals are actually
able to do that I'm not sure maybe
you could see animals over time for some
reason lowering the value of survive at
all costs gradually until other
objectives might become more important
maybe I don't know how evolutionarily
how that how that gets off the ground
that just seems like that would have
such a strong pressure against it you
know
just imagine a you know a population
with with with a lower um you know with
if if you were a mutant in a population
that had less of a uh less of a survival
imperative would you would your genes
outperform the others it seems no is
there such a thing as population
selection because maybe suicide is a way
uh for organisms to decide that
themselves that they're not fit for the
environment somehow yeah that's a that's
a really uh Contra you know population
level selection is a is a kind of a deep
controversial area but it's tough
because on the face of it if that was
your genome it wouldn't get propagated
because you would die and then your
neighbor who didn't have that would
would have all the kids it feels like
there could be some deep truth there
that we're not understanding
um what about you yourself as one
biological system are you afraid of
death
to be honest I'm more concerned with uh
especially now getting older and having
helped a couple of people pass I think
about what's a um
what's a good way to go basically like
nowadays I don't know what that is I you
know sitting in a you know a facility
that sort of tries to uh stretch you out
as as long as you can that doesn't seem
that doesn't seem good and there's not a
lot of opportunities to sort of
um I don't know sacrifice yourself for
something useful right there's not
terribly many opportunities for that in
modern society so I don't know that's
that's that's more of I'm not I'm not
particularly worried about uh death
itself but uh I've I've seen it happen
uh and and it's not it's not pretty and
I don't know what what a better what a
better alternative is so the existential
aspect of it does not
worry you deeply the fact that this ride
ends
no it began I mean the ride began right
so there was I don't know how many
billions of years before that I wasn't
around so that's okay but isn't the
experience of life
it's almost like feels like you're
Immortal because the way you make plans
the way you think about the future I
mean if if you re if you look at your
own personal Rich experience
yes you can understand okay eventually I
died there's people I love that have
died so surely I will die and it hurts
and so on but like it sure doesn't it's
so easy to get lost and feeling like
this is going to go on forever yeah it's
a little bit like the people who say
they don't believe in Free Will right I
mean you can say that but but when you
go to a restaurant you still have to
pick a soup and stuff so right so so I
don't know if I know I've I've actually
seen that that happen at lunch with a
with a well-known philosopher and he
wouldn't believe in Free Will and you
know the waitress came around and he was
like well let me see I was like what are
you doing you're gonna choose a sandwich
right so um it's I think it's one of
those things I think you you can know
that you know you're not going to live
forever but you can't you can't it's not
practical to live that way unless you
know so you buy insurance and then you
do some stuff like that but but but
mostly you know
um I think you just you just live as if
uh as if as if you can make plans